[Musique]
down the world a été joueur de football
professionnel pour les patriots de la
nouvelle angleterre un avocat reconnu
mais depuis des mois il brode et ilc ou
une façon de se rapprocher de l'esprit
de ses ancêtres
thomas est devenu une kulish ovi store
en cette veille de mardi gras d'awad
warzee fébrile il met la dernière main à
son costume de l'année et pose pour le
photographe du journal local el ouardi
perpétue la tradition vieille d'au moins
deux siècles des indiens noir masqués
donné aux pays africains skate au xviiie
siècle les autochtones aide les esclaves
africains à échapper à leurs maîtres et
à vivre en homme libre et je dessine
peint à mach 2 d'ocz web et bento le
pays ou inscrits dont ce folklore a
aujourd'hui une forte connotation
politique
l ego
oui c'est vrai et gauze were hotel & go
joué le barillet et gros sous et deux à
tf1
il n'y a pas dans chaque année dao
imagine un costume qui évoque la
difficile histoire des noirs aux états
unis
2 où elle peinait marie horeau farhi
il invite parents et amis au dévoilement
de cette pièce consacrée cette année à
une révolte d'esclaves
[Musique]
le lendemain du dévoilement direction
alger un faubourg de la nouvelle orléans
loin du tourisme et du quartier français
le phénomène d un viennois masse qui
s'est raffinée à l'époque de la
ségrégation raciale qui a perduré à la
nouvelle orléans jusqu'à la fin des
années 60 les noirs étaient exclues des
célébrations des blancs au centre ville
encore aujourd'hui symboliquement les
indiens noir masqués se rencontrent et
danse dans les faubourgs de la ville où
la population est noire
les afro américains ont à ce jour en
revenu moyen de 40 % inférieur à celui
des blancs dans ce quartier la moitié
des enfants vivent sous le seuil de la
pauvreté
et c'est pour cette raison que down the
world dance avec d'autres dans les rues
de la nouvelle-orléans déguisé en
autochtone
émilie dubreuil radio-canada nouvelle
orléans
[Musique]